reading is the strongest
signal for success in the future that
i've ever seen
for the next 90 days spend the first 90
minutes of your workday
on your single most important
opportunity
to move the needle in your industry
everybody's pointing fingers
instead of saying we've had it really
good for a bunch of years
and the question is now what is our
competitor revealing about our own
weaknesses that we can
learn to improve want to be happy build
a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you as well
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
habits that the one percent use to get
better
every day enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one read more with oprah winfrey i heard
jesse jackson speak when i was a kid
saying that
uh excellence is the best deterrent to
racism
excellence is the best deterrent to
sexism and so i went home and i put that
on my mirror
and that really became my motto so that
in the third grade
i was one of those kids that made all
the kids sick because
i was the first one to turn in the book
report and i was the you know read the
most books and i would say
reading is the strongest
signal for success in the future that
i've ever seen
it is the strongest strongest strongest
i got my first job in radio
uh when i was 16 years old because i've
been broadcasting since i was 16 years
old
but my first job i got because i was a
great reader
when you are a great reader you can
articulate and speak
and command the english language in ways
that other people cannot
and people think you're a lot smarter
than you are lots of times because
you're a great reader
i would say it's the absolute greatest
foundation
you can give your kids habit number two
spend your finest
hours wisely with robin sharma if you
want to achieve the results only
five percent achieve you've got to think
and produce and behave
like only five percent of the people on
the planet and the best people on the
planet in terms of creativity and
productivity are not spending their
finest hours
addicted to distraction they are doing
work
that matters they're not doing fake work
they're doing real work for the next 90
days
spend the first 90 minutes of your work
day on your
single most important opportunity to
move
the needle in your industry and i'll
repeat that again with great respect
because it's so important i believe to
your productivity
the 1991 rule is simply for the next 90
days
spend the first 90 minutes of your work
day on your single
most game changing opportunity because
what happens
a lot of us get to work and we spend our
best hours
on our least important activities we get
to work
and we start checking our social feed we
get to work and we
check our text we get to work and we
chit chat
at the water cooler about the latest tv
show that we watched last night
and research has shown that the morning
hours are when you have the most focus
when you have the most
energy and when you have the most
willpower
and so you want to use that first 90
minutes you know that is
that is game time that's show time the
second
piece of technology to create
exponential productivity
is what i call tight bubbles of total
focus
your environment is so important and if
you look at b
performers or c producers they really
don't pay a lot of attention to their
environment
and so they get very distracted there's
lots of noises
their phones are going off maybe there's
news in the background
maybe there's messy environments all
around them
maybe there's toxic people what i'm
suggesting to you
as the second piece of technology to
really 100
times your productivity is this install
environments of tight bubbles of total
focus
the way i run my work life on certain
days
i am very hard to reach and i challenge
you with great love and respect
be very hard to reach during key times
of your week
i mean i see a lot of people and it's
not judging them it's just observing
them
every time their phone rings they check
it or they have you know these loud
notifications
so they're constantly being distracted
and we know what the research says
the research says we spend 2.1 hours a
day
in distraction we spent and it takes
21 minutes to refocus your focus after
you've been distracted
so if you are being distracted by
notifications checking your phone
checking your twitter feed checking your
facebook feed looking on instagram
checking all the different platforms
that is going to destroy your focus
habit number three be intentional with
david meltzer there's a field of
intention
and i have a kind of steroid version of
what i learned from dr dyer
and i believe that intention needs to be
consistent
every day okay persistent without fail
without quit
and enjoyed for the pursuit of your
potential a higher vibration of the
truth
let me put this into context if for
example i can give everyone a gift say
thank you is the best intention that you
can have it gives you perspective
makes your past awesome your present
better and your future brighter two
words thank you
right so i tell people make an attention
of yours to be grateful
you get stopped at a life say thank you
because it probably
the universe is unraveling something and
saving you yeah not slowing you down oh
i love that
right so i need that one it's awesome
yeah i love that and so i live in this
intention now here's where you get
your people lose your body has cellular
memory
proven your mind has neural pathways and
your dna has a memory and
energy yep that's your core energy if
you don't do something every day
consistently
this is what happens the power of
intention has an accelerator
of exponential results so we're relying
on a on a bad system
but we need to know what we want so if
we start thinking saying and doing
every day what we want eventually
minimum 21 days
it'll go to our subconscious and create
a neural pathway in our brain
if i want to be grateful i do it day one
it's x to the first power day two to
x to the second x to the third x to the
fourth now i go get wasted stay out of
night
and i'm an egotistic narcissist who they
think of others
now it's x to the zero power i've now
zeroed out those other days
now i start over yeah what happens at
the end of the month
is i sit there and go wow i did this all
month this is the way the human mind
works
and i'm like why don't i get the results
that dave gets yes
well because you zeroed it out three
nights yep yep and i'm getting
to the 31st power you're exactly right
and it's the same thing why people they
just
they're 99 percenters they don't realize
how the body-minded soul works
hey this is dave meltzer and i'm going
to read my favorite paragraph of my
friend
evan carmichael's book build to serve
here's the secret dream big act small
it is important to dream big your big
dreams will motivate you
it'll inspire you to keep going when
things get tough
it'll be a rallying call for your
partners suppliers
customers and future employees
keep a hold of your huge dream
and then act small
find the smallest possible way to get
started
to take the first step to get some
momentum going
dream big but act small habit number
four
exercise discipline with jocko willing
being in the military
does not make you a disciplined person
being from a disciplined
family does not make you a disciplined
person being in a disciplined group does
not
make you a disciplined person what makes
you a disciple person is choosing to be
disciplined
so
[Music]
yeah i i and and also as far as telling
people to man up
um which you know when someone says how
do i
get up early every day i say get up
early every day how do i stop eating
sugar stop eating sugar
that's the definition of mana but
obviously it's not just men that need
discipline in their life
i don't think i use that term but what i
do tell people
is to get after it that's what i tell
people to get after it
yeah i tell people to do the things that
they know they're supposed to do
right there's things that you know
you're supposed to do as a human being
things that you know are going to
improve your life do those things
there's things that you know are going
to make you a worse person and make your
life worse
don't do those things don't do the
things that are making you weaker
start doing the things that are going to
make you stronger and smarter
and faster and healthier and going to
make you a better human being and i'll
say the same thing to this guy
you want to be more disciplined get
after it
that's it man get up early do some kind
of workout eat good foods
clean your room make a list of things
that you're supposed to do in your life
and then wake up in the morning and do
those things that you put on the list
that's what discipline is
[Music]
and no it is not easy but you're not
going to get it from anyone else
but you and it's worth it
and it is the thing that is going to
bring you freedom
habit number five learn from competition
with simon sinek
any participant in any industry can get
lazy
when there is little change in how that
industry operates
and then when there's a sudden change to
how the industry operates
everybody gets angry panics and points a
finger
i'll give you an example okay i'll give
you two examples
example number one taxi companies around
the world hate uber
right now here's the reality
the app that calls a car not proprietary
you can call a taxi with it with an app
right
paying with your phone not proprietary
any taxi can do that as well the reason
uber is eating taxi companies
for lunch is because it's a better
product
and the taxi companies around the world
could have
a shitty product because you're the only
game in town
and we had no choice and now you have a
competitor and instead of competing
you're getting angry i would gladly take
more cabs
than call services if i got in the cab
and he said hi and it was clean
and i had a nice chat with him and he
wasn't on the phone and he wasn't
smoking and all of these things
and i had some leg room i'd gladly
gladly gladly has nothing to do with the
app
the pay mechanism has to do with the
fact that
juno and lyft are just better
is it just better experience better
product that's why i take them
it costs a dollar more whatever i'll pay
for it it's not even a price thing
i have no idea if it's cheaper or more
expensive i actually never compared
the same goes for starbucks right so
there was a
a lot of people hate starbucks because
they put mom and pops out of business
right the reality is the complete
opposite
that when starbucks moves into a
neighborhood mom and pops
coffee shops actually do better for two
reasons
one starbucks attracts more customers so
there's just more people
and the second reason is there is a
ground swell of
giving back to the local and so more
people go to the mom and pop
right the ones that go out of business
the ones that refuse to compete
i'll give you a real life example this
goes back a few years
a real life example i'm lactose
intolerant right so
i don't have milk in my coffee and there
was a time
where it wasn't a foregone conclusion
that every coffee shop had soy milk or
almond milk or something
so i would always go into the mom and
pop that was across the street from
starbucks always go to the mom and pop
and i'd say
do you guys have any soy milk and they
go nope i go like thank you and i would
walk out
those went out of business because
i went to starbucks he's right i went to
starbucks
now had starbucks moved in and they went
across the street and said let's see
what starbucks has
we should offer soy milk maybe it's time
for us to
replace this ripped couch that we've had
for 15 years
because it's really nice across there
and it's really gross here
it's the ones who got angry and refused
to compete that went out of business i
think retail's the same
everybody's pointing fingers instead of
saying
we've had it really good for a bunch of
years
and the question is now what is our
competitor revealing about our own
weaknesses that we can
learn to improve because that's what
competition does competition reveals
your weaknesses to you
and when you had no competition you
didn't know where you were weak
this is the problem with being the best
at anything
uh because you don't know where your
your faults are and then somebody
undermines you because
they can see your faults before you can
habit number six visualize success with
sarah blakely
i visualized this for myself when i was
selling copiers door-to-door
i had a very clear vision of what my
life was going to be like
and i encourage everyone to do it take a
snap photo of what success
looks like for you are you how many
employees do you have or how much are
you making
where do you live are you sitting at a
table with world leaders are you
standing on a stage in new york city
giving a speech
and hold on to that that snapshot and
you will subconsciously start to make
decisions that get you there
and so my snap photo for myself when i
was going door-to-door to sell copiers
was to be self-employed invent a product
that i could sell to lots of people and
not just
one copier to each person and create a
business for myself that would continue
to
fund itself if i wasn't present i wanted
money to be generated
without me having to be there i was that
specific in my vision
and habit number seven the last one
before some very special bonus clips
is diversify with ed mylett
diversity is the pathway to richness
diversity is the pathway to richness and
i mean diversity in two forms
the people in your life and the
experiences of your life
and without that diversity i'm so
concerned in our culture today that i
see us become
more and more tribal less and less
diverse both in our friendships and our
relations we don't talk to each other we
talk at each other
and more and more we hang around people
just like us don't we
and they kind of reinforce our beliefs
and our way of living
and we just kind of go in this circle it
feels good it's like eating cake and it
feels really good but it doesn't grow us
and then the second thing is the lack of
diverse experiences that we're
giving ourselves access to and so i
looked up diversity by the way
in the dictionary and basically it means
variety
we've all heard the saying that variety
is the spice of life
and i know during this time with covid
and the global pandemic and
high unemployment and political
polarization and
all the things that are happening most
people say hey life ain't so spicy right
now
and i want to bring some spice back to
your life and you can do it for free
on no budget that spice that variety
comes through diversity so the
experience that i had this week that i
wanted to share with you and i can only
talk about it for a few minutes because
every time i get going i can't finish
sentences but i
dropped my son off at college yesterday
and um
can't do it sorry i just my boy left me
yesterday
it hit me much harder than i thought it
would and it's hitting me even harder
again today
and i think one of the reasons is is
that i liked our kind of lack of
variety our lack of diversity i had them
under my roof every single day
but what i keep reminding myself of is
how amazing these next four years can be
for my son why because he's about to
have the most diverse experience
of his lifetime isn't he he's already
meeting people that he didn't grow up
around people from different backgrounds
different countries
different economic situations different
religions
he's going to introduce to different
ways of thinking he's going to have
decisions and choices to make
good and bad isn't he during these years
but any of you that went to college
or have sent a child off the college
it's four of the best years of most
people's lives why it's the most diverse
years of their life
so if that's true for max i got to be
excited for him don't i
as emotional as i am for myself but it's
also true for you
it's true for me there's a direct
correlation and connection
between the amount of diversity in our
life a variety
and how happy we are how much we're
growing by the way how wealthy you'll
get too
and so when i dropped max off i you know
i want to tell you first about making
decisions i said max you're going to
have a lot of decisions you're going to
have to make in your life
when you're here for the first time and
when i say diversity and variety and
chase diversity right i don't mean
things that you
are new are knowingly aware of could be
harmful to you
so when you're offered a drug or a
particular drink or some situation or
decisions you got to make max there's
only two things you need to remember
so this is the next thing i'd have you
all right now i said max you need to
remember
who you are as a man your identity
and number two what you stand for and if
every decision comes your way
you just remind yourself who am i and
what do i stand for and is this choice
this decision consistent with that
then you'll make the right decision and
i know that for a fact by the way for
you
in your life who are you and what do you
stand for and have you been living that
way recently
because i think you love all people i
think you want to chase experiences i
think you want memories and moments in
your life and you want to be happier
all of that is in this place that most
of us avoid as we get older
which is new things diverse things
different people different ways of
thinking
you're taught in the world right now
aren't you man these people are
different they're your enemy
everybody in the world both the left
political party and the right political
party i'll tell you your life's messed
up because of these people
it's not your fault it's their fault
both parties do it
right it's interesting so many people
say you don't know what it's like to be
me
but they seem to be an expert on what
it's like to be you
maybe those of you that think you're an
expert on what it's like to be somebody
else or you've got an opinion about
somebody's life ask yourself if you've
walked in their shoes
ask yourself if you've had their
experiences and if you haven't why don't
you start to get to know people like
that and maybe your opinion could evolve
or change
or at least you'd have an experience
wouldn't you that's unique and different
than the one you're having with the same
three four five people
you talk to to go to the same three four
five places
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i wanna know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week
when you just watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action
but when you watch a video you get
motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
percent
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through
on the plan you set for yourself so i
want to know
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your plan of action for the
next week
leave it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate you
if you want to make a big change you
have to get desperate enough
you have to get so sick of how you're
living right now that it forces you to
change
you have to tell yourself that you never
want to be in this spot again
you're done when you feel that
frustration
you're ready to change but until that
happens you stay stuck where you are
knowing that you're capable of more but
never actually doing anything
to get it so there's a great book called
good to great where the idea is
moving from good to great and that good
is the enemy of great
if you want greatness it's actually
easier right now to be
in a really negative spot because it
forces you to change
but when you're good you're good you
don't have to make the change it's not
important enough to you because you're
good you're okay you're fine
and a lot of struggle that people have
is you're just good right now
your life is probably good it's good you
can be grateful for everything you've
got
awesome you're feeling good that you
don't hate your life every single day
but that lack of frustration and pain
means you don't do what's necessary to
go off and create that great future for
yourself
as an example when i broke my neck last
year
in denver i broke it into spots and
compressed my spine and
had a concussion and all that one of the
things that happened was i had i had
massive shoulder
pain here like in my shoulder blade it
really hurt and the doctors at the time
said there was nothing wrong and that
when i when i healed from my neck
that would heal on its own it didn't so
when i came back
to toronto and a couple months later my
neck was healing i could finally take
off my cast
my my shoulder blade was still hurting
so i went to the doctor and he said you
should go do physio and so i went to do
physio
and i did physio for my neck for just
gaining motion because i had it in a
cast for
two months and even doing this was
massively hurting
and i mentioned this and she said don't
worry about it once you fix your neck
that's gonna go away and it didn't
and so i got frustrated that i'm sitting
here with all of this
shoulder blade pain like how do i get
rid of this and i just decided enough i
don't want to live in pain anymore
i gotten so used to the pain that it
just became part of my daily
living and i thought i don't want to
live with this shoulder pain anymore
and so that frustration led to massive
action so my next step was i went to a
chiropractor i had a great chiropractor
who's helped me with a bunch of injuries
over the years
and we did 14 sessions together normally
when i go to him it's two or three
sessions and then
i'm pretty much fixed 14 sessions and it
still
wasn't getting better and he kept saying
i don't know why it's not getting better
but
keep doing it and hopefully it's gonna
get better
can't solve it fine we keep going i
started
interviewing experts on my instagram
live brought in people who i could ask
questions to talking about
posture talking about stretching talking
about activities i could do to try to
make it better
i adjusted the height of my stand-up
trampoline i make these videos on a
trampoline
every day by the way it takes a lot of
effort to to not jump while i'm making
videos i have to hold on to the desk
but i adjusted the height of my
trampoline i moved my monitors
up so if i'm looking at my monitor now i
look up that my monitors are up here
because we spend so much time down
looking down at food at our phone at the
table
that you know my neck was here maybe
pulling on the muscles back here
so now i look up when i'm looking at my
computer and then looking down for other
things during the day
i adjusted the height of my stand-up
desk i i got a vertical
mouse to play with right to change my
arm positioning i got a new keyboard an
ergonomic
keyboard that the the how this sits is
the wrists are higher than the keyboard
most people put the keyboards up like
this
where instead minor mine goes the other
way my wrist is on top and
the hands are pointing down i got this
thing here
which is a elbow rest so as i'm typing
i rest my elbow here and then i can type
with my hand
and use the mouse wherever it needs to
go so it's the weight of
my arm is supported by this whatever
this thing is robotic arm kind of i
guess
that's attached to my desk and all of
these things combined
started healing my shoulder finally
after all the doctors were telling me
it'll just go away on its own and it
wasn't going away on its own
finally the pain led to the frustration
which led to me
wanting to live a life that was pain
free and taking massive action a lot of
things not working and then finally
making some progress
that's where you need to get to in your
life that's we need to get to in your
business that the great life that you
want
that might be on your vision board and
living on the beach and working with
people you love and everything that you
want to do
it's not important enough yet for you to
get that and so you don't take enough
action towards actually making that
happen
you have to get to the point where it's
enough it's an i'm tired of this
i can't keep living like this something
has to change i actually
want to make that life happen and when
you feel that frustration
then you'll take the necessary action
it's so simple
like when you get the life is really
short and you felt that before but
either by you were threatened or you've
had someone
near and dear die but when you have that
real essence in you that says
life is short have reverence for it live
it that's a really big thing i got that
at 19 and i learned specifically
that if we have a moment of cognition
before the end of our life
we tend to ask questions to evaluate if
we're happy
so if i have any impact in the world
it's
gonna come from that experience where i
learned that the ultimate lesson is
determine what the questions you're
going to ask at the end of your life are
going to be
find out those questions what will you
ask at the end of your life
to evaluate your life so that you would
know if you were happy with your life
like
figure out those questions and then live
each day
intentionally so you're happy with the
answers at the end for me the answers
the questions i had were did i live
which i hadn't
i hadn't been living my life i've been
thinking about taking my life
did i love no my heart was broken
and i put up all these walls to keep out
other people and i always say you know
sometimes the walls we put up
to keep out the bad guys prevent the
good guys from getting in
and suddenly in our own self-protection
we block out the very thing we want
which is
connection and i learned that i would
ask
did i matter you know 22 years ago
on a dark caribbean night i'm standing
on the crumpled hood of a car
bleeding out my friend
and i just wrecked a car he's screaming
at top of his lungs he's bleeding we
know if we're going to live
and i'm standing on this car looking
down all this blood
and i'm in terror and i just remember
looking down the hood and just thinking
did i even matter you know
and i hated the answer at that time in
life because a 19 year old kid
i didn't know about impact theory for
real
i didn't know to think about that you
some you know young kids sometimes they
don't know to think about that
i didn't know to think about legacy
meaning did i matter i didn't think i
did
but the good news is i'm a good learner
and i felt like i got a second chance
from god that night and
i learned that it was really important
for me
to figure out how do i live and how do i
love and how do i matter in such a way
that if i face my death again
i'll know i've earned the second chance
and so what i want to tell people and
the impact i want is i just want people
to
know
know your questions man live
intentionally and earn the life that
you've been given because this moment's
a blessing
so earn this moment and live
intentionally if i
immediately when i wake up i can't check
my phone in fact i put it on airplane
mode and i move it
i got that from ariana huffington who's
amazing and she's like
is your phone still by your bed she goes
airplane mode on the other side of the
room
you know um so that
and then i just know so many people roll
over and grab their phone and to me
that's like russian roulette you put a
bullet in the gun and you spin it
it's like what if the email says the
deal didn't happen numbers are down
life's not working out like and
immediately for me it's like you open up
and
and this little box is gonna dictate the
first couple hours or maybe the whole
day by what you see
so i just i just won't look at my phone
when i first wake up
so but when i first open my eyes this is
all and i like doing things
quick for me because i want to get to
the gym because the only time of day
i'll go if i try to wait till the
afternoon it doesn't work for me
so as soon as i wake up i immediately
try to think of something
i'm grateful for which everybody knows
that and thinks about it but i've
i play this game myself on how far i can
lower the bar
meaning i i try to do a gratitude
journal about three years ago
and after about five weeks i ran out of
stuff to say i'm like i already wrote my
kids and this
and life like what did i put in here
like and then i was like wow
150 000 people die every single day you
can google it that's the number
it's like some days i wake up i'm just
like i'm here awesome
and i let i feel that silly little thing
like i'm here or
or i'll be like oh my god the sheets
feel softer than they've ever felt
and i'll literally think to myself these
sheets are really good like
what a third of the world sleeps on the
on a dirt floor
and i have sheets and an amazing bed and
look at the view i have
and that's enough just because the way i
know is i'm just just
tweaking my brain enough to be in a
grateful place it doesn't have to be
this for me
and you guys might have better practices
i'm not talking about a half hour
gratitude meditation i just need
one little thing or i pick up a book if
i'm reading one of the books that you
have on the shelf
i'll pick and i'll just pick three
sentences and read something empowering
and i'll get that state of mind for my
brain and then i think about
one win i had the day before because i
know as entrepreneurs
as somebody searching for success we
never give ourselves credit
we never treat a friend the way we treat
ourselves it's like i know i've had days
i've gone till 10 o'clock at night go
man i got nothing done today
was the biggest lie like we beat
ourselves up we just we're like these
racehorses we wouldn't even treat a
racehorse that we owned as bad as we
treat ourselves right so
i wake up and i'll do a quick little
gratitude and i'll say what was one win
yesterday that i accomplished i'm like
wow
you did do that yesterday and then i'll
think of one win i want to do that day
like what i'm going to need a million
things done today but what's a must
today that would be a great win
and then for me then i immediately go
downstairs in my house and i drink
i felt like i fed my my mind and i want
to feed my body
so for me i've been doing the same drink
forever i do apple cider vinegar
lemon mct oil a scoop of green powder
and uh mix that up and i down that and
then i immediately got to go to the gym
you know that um wave that you feel or
your tongue gets numb or you get
tightness in your cheeks
or you freeze you know when that happens
based on the science there is only
a 90-second chemical release
in your body it's called the 90 second
rule when your body starts to
stomach starts to flutter when your
heart starts to race when you feel this
feeling of fear that you have that's
unique to you
based on the science there's a 90-second
rule and
all of the chemical release that's
happening because your body is going
into a state of being alert
it only sticks around for 90 seconds
as long as you don't let your thoughts
race if your thoughts start to race
you'll start to agitate the situation
the next time that your body
goes into a state of alert stomach gets
tight you feel frozen
you get stuck you feel your neck when
the body starts to do that
number one just remember
it means your body is getting ready to
be alert and pay attention doesn't and
it does not mean you're gonna lose
control it does not mean you're in
danger it does not mean to stop or to
shut up
i want you to take a deep breath
count to five five four three two one
that's it
and realize that the hormones that just
got released because you're about to do
something they only last 90 seconds
that's it
you can breathe slowly you can count to
90 you can get up and walk around you
can do 90 seconds of jumping jacks
you can meditate for 90 seconds you can
ground your feet in your chair
and wiggle a minute so that you feel
your body in your chair
and take deep breaths and what you're
going to
find is that you're going to be blown
away
you're going to be blown away because
what you're going to see is that
in 90 seconds flat
you can go from being somebody who has
an
upset stomach and who would normally not
go talk to your boss who would
normally not walk into that gym who
would normally
not make that call in 90 seconds flat
you can manipulate your body state to
calm down
and you will notice that your thoughts
do not race your thoughts calm down
you're in full control and now you can
speak up
and now you can show up have you heard
of the saying that money doesn't buy
happiness and i say neither does poverty
you see a lot of people they like to
make that connection well you know i
would rather
be happy than rich or wealthy
or yeah money is not that important
or that it's okay like if we set our
goals too high
then we will get disappointed i don't
know about other
rich people but i have been rich and
i've been poor
and i could tell you which is a lot
better
better
to film my video in a luxury suv
than on a bicycle boss on the bicycle
would not look so good
so what i'm talking about is it has
nothing to do with that if you are a
happy person
money will make you happier it will make
you give you more
tools and more currency to do things to
make an impact
if you are a sad depressed miserable
person
more money will make you depressed sad
and more miserable it has nothing to do
with each other
people like to use that as an excuse to
justify
their failures to justify their lack of
ambition
and they say well you know what it's i
just want to be okay
i don't need a lot of money i don't need
to be wealthy and i just want to be
happy what i
say is why not both why can't you have
both
why can you be happy and wealthy at the
same time why can you be happy
wealthy and healthy at the same time why
do we have to choose
why can you not have it all it's like
saying that while you can have the cake
and eat it too then my question is
what is the damn point of having that
kick you want to have the kick and you
want to eat it too
that's what it is so we have a lot of
these misconceptions and
lies and myths that people believe in
that are not true
and very often they are simply excuses
to justify
that's all it is they are justifications
and i could tell you that most people
who are successful financially
most not all most are pretty happy most
are
pretty happy because they don't have to
worry a lot of things that most people
are worried about you don't have to
worry about
the bills you don't have to worry about
your car payment you don't have to worry
about
your house payment so a lot of the the
struggles and the hassles
that a lot of people have a lot of the
simple things that you're worried about
when you are successful when you have
more
financial means you don't have to worry
about those things you could focus
on other things that may be more
important you could spend more time with
your
family you could help the people that
they need help with so don't buy into
the whole
of oh are people happy already no
do both be wealthy as well as
be happy there was a young man who tried
his
level best to clear his exams at
university
but he repeatedly failed and finally
he just gave up thinking
that marriage would be the best way to
make him responsible
his family got him married
after the marriage the man took up a job
as a primary school teacher but
due to lack of experience was mocked
by the students and finally removed
by the school authorities in just a few
weeks time
when he returned home that day his wife
wiped his tears and converted him
she said to him you can teach young kids
only if you've taken formal training or
at least
have some experience of teaching kids
and for you you didn't study teaching at
university
nor have you dealt with kids earlier
so how do you know how to teach kids
don't be too sad about it when god says
yes to your prayer he gives you
what you want but when he says no to
your prayer
here's something better for you
probably there is a better more suitable
job
waiting for you out there gathering some
hope
the man kept trying to find
opportunities
and when he did finally find one he was
once again chucked out of the job
due to his slowness yet again his wife
tried to encourage him by saying i'm
sure
there are people who are skilled and
experienced at that job
and their experience comes from many
years at it as for you
you were in school trying to teach kids
all this why
so how could you acquire the needed
skills
don't worry when god says no to your
prayer
he gives you something better but when
he says
wait to your prayer he gives you
the best the man kept
trying his luck with several jobs
which never lasted more than a couple of
weeks
at best months each time
he would return back home dejected
and depressed and his loving wife
would comfort him never once
was she disappointed or resentful
by the time the man was in his 30s he'd
found his calling
and had acquired a flair in languages
he ended up being a counselor in school
for those
kids who are challenged in hearing and
speaking
and a little later he opened his
own school for specially abled kids
in a couple of years he set up a chain
of stores
in different cities and provinces
selling
apparatus and equipment for the
specially abled
and went on to become a
multi-millionaire
one day the now rich man
asked his wife when i was so negative
about my own future how
could you have so much faith
in me the reply that his wife gave him
was simple yet very profound and
inspiring
she said when a piece of land is not
suitable for planting wheat
we should try planting beans and after
all the years of
efforts if beans are not growing well we
should try planting fruits
or veggies and if the vegetation doesn't
work
we can scatter buckwheat seeds
these seeds will one day bloom into
flowers and on the very land itself
there will be one seed that will
germinate and grow
after having listened to the wife's
explanation
the man wept her faith in him
her love her patience her persistence
was actually responsible for the
successful
empire that they now owned
ladies and gentlemen no one in this
world
is useless the land may be very fertile
but you may not have figured out your
seed
yet it takes a while to figure out
what's your seed what works for you
but once you discover your seed
your passion your calling excellence
and abundant growth will simply be a
consequence
until then you need to believe
in yourself more so you need someone who
can believe in you
and keep you going till you see
your day if you try to control
the variety of situations that may pop
up in your face tomorrow morning
all that'll happen is you will become a
very limited life
you would step out into the world and do
whatever that needs to be done
only if you have an assurance no matter
what you walk into you will not lose
yourself
you will walk full stride otherwise
you'll only be a half a step
most human beings are half steps because
the fear of suffering
if this happens what will happen to me
if that happens what will happen to me
if you're well managed within yourself
you know how to manage your thought you
know how to manage your emotion
you know how to manage your body your
chemistry your energy if you know how to
manage all this
what does it matter if you walk into
hell i'm asking
if you are well managed if you are a
heaven within you
what does it matter where you go hell
also will be an interesting place to go
but if you are ill managed then you want
to be in a nice place
all the time you will not step out into
anything
i am not saying this is wrong this is
against nature
because in nature every life is aspiring
to be as much as it can be isn't it
every life is naturally aspiring this is
not a philosophy
this is not an ideology that you must do
this or that
it is natural and intrinsic for every
life
that you will do as much as it can
from an earthworm from a worm to an
insect to a bird
to an animal to a tree every one of them
are trying to be full-fledged life
if you go against this simply because of
the fear of suffering
then all possibilities of exploring the
nature of being human
the tremendous immensity of being human
is just lost upon humanity today you
will see this everywhere
when people say i am only human
they are talking about the limitations
of being human
they are not talking about the
possibilities of being human
isn't it when if we
are the most intelligent species on the
planet
if we are the most capable species on
the planet
should we be talking about our
possibilities or should we be talking
about our limitations
whenever anybody writes or says
oh we are human they are always
referring to their limitations
never to the possibilities of being
human this is because
the the most fundamental things have not
been taught in our education systems
how to handle your thought and your
emotion
your psychological drama has gone out of
control
so badly directed drama believe me
if it was a well-directed drama you
would take it to the conclusion that you
want
isn't it because it's a badly directed
drama just about
anybody can take charge of it who is the
director of your psychological drama
just about anybody isn't it anybody can
make it into a tragedy
i'm learning that i could be still i'm
learning that i could
be aware of my thoughts but then let
them go and i come back to focus
on a sound wave in this particular
meditation
and then what happens is over a period
of practice
you realize that you're basically your
body disappears
you're no longer in this physical thing
you're no longer having these
waves of thought after thought after
thought after thought after thought
after idea
positive negative and everything in
between and
in that space of recognizing that i'm
not my physical body i have a physical
body i'm not my thoughts i have thoughts
i'm not my emotions i have them
when you start to train yourself to use
your brain
better more efficiently more
productively
you realize that a i am one with
this you know incredible universe so
what's the big deal about that
well the big deal is that if i am one
with
this universe with this energy with
everyone and everything
and that's where everything percolates
from
is it possible that all my answers are
right here right now
anyway and the answer is yeah and so
meditation is about practicing and we
know that we have
uh different brain waves so right now as
people are watching or listening
you know they're in this beta brainwave
frequency where their
brain is oscillating at a certain
frequency and there's 50 different brain
waves going on at any given time
but what happens is when i move into
from beta to alpha to
theta delta or gamma i'm actually
accessing
and activating different parts of my
brain which now gives me
this deeper greater sense of awareness
of a much bigger you know onion
that i'm used to seeing so i'm living on
a layer of an onion
and what if i could see like 10 layers
up and 10 layers down
all of a sudden it's like wow look at
who i am
what i am who you are what you are and
in that realization in that awareness
i can now start to have different
choice choices made and so meditation
is a practice of awareness it's a
practice of going
internal instead of external which is
where most people live their lives every
day
whenever i'm doing anything i have a
simple question can i do it now
because if i can do something now number
one
i save myself a minimum of half the time
it'll take me twice as much time to do
something if i don't do it now
and two exponentially becomes less
successful
if you don't do something now you can
forget it you have to go back
i mean it just turns into a mess so
about 85 to 88
of the things that i'm approached with i
can do now hey you got a referral yeah
hold on
sometimes it's a little weird and quirky
during the meeting but i do it anyway
someone asked me i literally make the
induct introduction i cut our
conversation
hey you need to know this guy you and so
these little tips
of time and then the other side so i
give time tips because i believe time's
a construct
everybody has 24 hours a day it's how
productive and accessible can you
be in 24 hours the things we said no to
that were actually the trigger to a
hotter
to a streak to heater that we said i i
hope that heaven
is where it shows you what life would
have been based on choices
i loved that i didn't go to some
night where at night would have been
these two people that would have made
this deal with me like
i love knowing that like momentum is
based on choice that i've missed
momentum many times in my life and that
i've
gotten momentum many times in my life
and i love that part of the game
actually which is like
decisions actually matter and sometimes
when you have the humility to go to a
thing that doesn't seem right
you get you get something that triggers
a domino and sometimes when you go to
something you're like i mean
i remember sitting down there's one
meeting i remember very vividly with
howard schultz i had a meeting with
howard schultz
to kind of just i was getting hot
getting in this you know
and like i got connected i remember
sitting four minutes before i'm like i'm
about to walk in here
and i'm about to blow this dude's face
off and it's gonna be a foundational
thing
i walked in we had a 15-minute meeting
20-minute meeting and
nothing's happened and
i didn't feel like i had an off day i
felt like i gave it but it didn't click
whereas
when i went to go see jimmy iveen uh for
this meeting i'm like i'm gonna
blow his face off within three minutes
he's like you're next simon cal and he
casted me in the apple show playing in
the apps with will i am
gwen paltrow and jessica and if that
show actually got seen
unfortunately it was before all the ott
stuff and the way tv
like that would have been white and that
would have been one of the moments so
you know the reality is is that wow you
know like
i love that kind of and then i lo i'm
trying to think of like something good
where like
who'd i meet randomly like i'm trying to
think of a real logical thing well
you know i took a meeting with the jets
president at a bagel store because he
wanted to sell me a sky box
i told him about where the world was
going we became great friends that's
matt higgins who's on shark tank who's
steve ross's
right hand there that led to him leaving
the jets years later going
to steve austin dolphins that became the
gentleman who bought a piece of my
company
and like that beca that bagel meeting
became monster meeting for me and i
didn't know who matt higgins was going
into it so
i i i love chance i love momentum
and i love what starts momentum that's
where i just took this yeah
more than i need to remind everybody
right now say yes
you know one thing that i hate about
people that haven't achieved anything
and people that have achieved everything
they overvalue their time
and it's a tricky one if you haven't
gotten there yet
what's your people like gary i'm not
doing that pro bono work i should be
compensated i'm like bro
your word your work's worth nothing like
there's 700 000 video makers
that i can that i can tweet right now
like sorry like like when your work's
not worth anything
like when no humility and then and then
on the and then again no humility when
people get fancy they don't take i take
so many small meetings i do so many
things like tea with garyvee
in the morning during this covet crisis
to like just
help and once every eight thousand times
it helps me
if you want to do something
extraordinary you have one job
leave your fellow humans in awe
now when you think about holy my job
as a parent as an entrepreneur as an
athlete
as a speaker as a whatever you want to
be
you've got to get so good at that thing
that when people see you do it you make
them experience
the most potent human emotion and that
is awe to get that good
is a terrifying journey of
self-discovery
and confronting who you really are
because you cannot make change until you
acknowledge
where you're actually at now why
because it's not some new age woo
thing it is for real like if you
understand where you're weak
then you know where to spend your time
building
skills to me the gap between where you
are now
and where you want to go is a gap of
skill set
and once i realized that and i made the
choice
to believe that this whole brain
plasticity thing was real
even though it was being hotly debated
then i could shift my self-esteem
from being smart right
good worthy to being that of the learner
the learner is the only identity that i
have ever found
that is anti-fragile as nasim teleb says
things that are robust that are strong
that are tough
that can take just a lot of abuse before
they break they are still
ultimately defined by their breaking
point
something that is anti-fragile on the
other hand is something that the more
you attack it
the more it is pounded on the stronger
it gets now imagine being able to build
a belief system the thing that you build
your self-esteem around
if all of that we're tied to something
that is
truly anti-fragile that the more
somebody comes after it the more robust
it becomes
being a learner is that answer i got
done with that internship and it kind of
coincided with my blog
sort of i don't know if blowing up is
the word but becoming a thing that i
thought i could have so that was turning
into it was my point where it's like i
hate doing this and i'm very glad that i
kept a journal during this time
because now as an entrepreneur sometimes
when it gets hard you start to think
grass is greener it would be so much
easier if i went back and
just had a full-time job where i don't
have to think about work
i was thinking about that so i go back
and i read my journal entries
and it just straight up says like i feel
like i'm in prison
and i don't want to like put out there
like anybody working a full-time job as
a you know
corporate slave or something like that
i'm not one of those people but for me
it felt like that
uh and it's interesting when you look
back on things you don't remember
all like the bad or boring parts you
kind of look through
rose tinted glasses and you start
thinking well that might actually be
better than what i'm dealing with now
so keeping a journal was very helpful
nobody's happy 100 of the time that's
not how life works my friends it just
doesn't work that way
but you know you got to get up in the
morning and ask yourself
what can i do today it solves for three
problems for me
one most of us are working i'm going to
be working until i drop dead
so i want to get something done towards
that how can i do something for my
family because family first
all the time what can you do with your
family and if you're married or living
with your significant other
what can i do to help them because a
happy significant other you know the
happy wife happy life well these days
happy significant other happy life so
you got to balance all these three
things
with your day you're going to take care
of who you're living with you've got to
take care of your family got to take
care of your business
and when you're doing these things
you're going to find that they eat up 60
70 percent of your day
if your mind goes idle sometimes you can
get depressed it's happened to me too
you know things get on my mind i can't
sleep i worry about it
it's the wrong thing to do you've got to
think big picture
happiness is so hard to pursue and
anybody that tells you
they're happy a hundred percent of the
time is full of
that is so not true everybody deals with
stress
regardless of your situation i have
people that are friends of mine that are
incredibly wealthy and they're miserable
i know people that are struggling
financially
and are happy with their families so it
has nothing to do with money
happiness it's not a destination it's a
journey
every day is different and life is going
to throw you
some crazy stuff remember this
conversation when it happens
stay focused don't go nuts
try and stay focused on the things that
matter in your life
your job your family
[Music]
those are basically it and the things
you love
you know if you love to play music you
love art you got to spend some time with
that too
so between six and nine i'm gonna set up
my first three things to do that morning
i'm probably gonna work out in my case
because i'm a father i'm gonna spend
time with my kids
then i'm gonna come back i'm gonna take
a shower i'm gonna get ready have some
breakfast
and be ready for a 9 a.m meeting nine to
noon
between nine and noon maybe i have phone
calls maybe i'm working on a project
maybe i'm shooting a video
i'll basically have those notes again
every line
every line on this page should be
filled up noon i'm gonna take a quick
lunch maybe 10 or 15 minutes have a bite
to eat
or i'm gonna spend a longer lunch but
it'll always be with a client
three to six six to nine i'm cranking
down
i'm turning it off i'm going to sleep if
you over
commit and under deliver if you can't
get to everything that's better
than having blank space on this calendar
now the right side is why i built the
10x planner
as a journal schedule planner
daytime or day runner call it what you
want your goals
these four or five lines right here are
going to be the most important way to
start your day because this is your
purpose
this is why you're living your life this
is the reason you're getting up
and going into work each day underneath
this you're going to see quote of the
day
what is your quote today this is a very
creative two lines
that's going to cause you to think about
what you stand for that day
these are your targets things you want
to accomplish this day calls you want to
make appointments you want to have
deals you want to close people you need
to see somebody you got to get in front
of
this is your exact target something
measurable then what do we have
successes so so important don't wait
till the end of the week or the end of
the month to write down your successes
what did you do today you went to the
dentist and had your teeth cleaned
boom that's a success for me that's a
major success
because i hate freaking dentists and by
the way make sure when you put your
successes down here
tweet me every once in a while and i'll
make sure i either retweet you or i'll
follow you or i'll get you more
followers
last thing write your goals down again
you wrote them down this morning you
wrote them down at night i can't tell
you how valuable this is okay
you write your goals down once a year
i'm gonna write mine down 700
times a year who wins this game a guy
smarter than me
taller than me better looking than me
better connected than me
writes his goals down once or twice
years and i write mine down
700 times a year
who wins it won't be taller it won't be
richer
it won't be better looking it'll be the
guy that writes his goals down
twice a day every day how did you get
that mentality of just being like
i need to get over this like i need to
get over myself you know trial and error
you know you grow up and you make game
winning shots and it's awesome
you come back the next day and miss a
game when it's shot and it's misery
and then the next day comes and you're
back playing again and you understand
that life has this cyclical nature where
it's
you know what you do on monday it's
fantastic but then tuesday's a bad day
but guess what there's wednesday
so are we just supposed to live our
lives like this the whole time you know
versus just staying like this and
understanding that it's really just a
journey of
evolution every day it's just constant
improvement constant curiosity
constantly getting better
the results don't really matter uh it's
the
figuring out that matters yeah and we
all get obsessed about the results
yeah like we get obsessed about like the
output yeah not the input of not
figuring it out and not like
changing things well you said trial and
error like the experimenting yeah
we forget to do that it's unfortunate
man like i've seen a lot of players
um especially now you know in youth
basketball dealing with that
um you have players that are like bigger
and faster and stronger
and you know their coaches are just
coaching them for results
you know we're just going to use your
size that because you're bigger than
every other 12 year old out there
to dominate today and but they're not
growing
right so they're just based on that
result but they're not focused on
growing this young
child yeah into becoming a better
athlete and through that
teaching them how to become a more
well-rounded person
and we're missing that the next one is
organization
i can't tell you how much better my life
is and anybody watching this
will be if you wake up every single day
and you take 10 minutes i have yellow
notepads sitting all around my house
i got that from bill gates bill gates
built microsoft at 17 by locking himself
in a hotel room with six
yellow notepads and he wrote out the
whole basic code
for dos and things that built microsoft
okay he became the richest man in the
world 18 years straight because
he was organized enough to lock himself
in a room
and think through his day and so what i
try to do and whenever i do this i have
a great day whenever i don't
i notice it be organized a little bit
10 minutes i actually have this little
couch thing outside of my shower
and i put a notepad by it i take a
shower when i wake up i walk over to
that i kind of sit there
and i just write out i mean it can be as
little as three main projects you want
to get done that day
fear comes in many forms there's some
things that
i can't get over and i'll always be
scared of
but i take the positive from it like i'm
never so confident i'm gonna win
it's probably the fact that i'm scared
to fail no one forces me to do anything
i'll make the decision myself and if i
didn't want to do it i wouldn't
so when i'm faced with the challenge i
just embrace it and what can one man do
except forgive his best
if you fail you try again if you win
you try again and get better so as long
as you maintain and you stay consistent
you'll forever be a winner and a
champion and the people who love you
in their rights because they support you
nevertheless as long as you're
trying again and again and again if
while you're writing your book
if while you're recording your podcast
if you're sitting there going
i hope this is going to be number one
this better be number one i hope i sell
more
i hope i sell more copies than this
person who's launching at the same time
because that's the only way
well guess what now the quality of your
output right now has just
dropped because guess what you're now
living 75
in the future and you're 25 right now
and guess what this 25
is gonna define that future goal and
result and your happiness and you're
happy whether you get the result enough
totally
whereas for me when i was writing my
book and of course i want my book to be
a best-selling book
of course i want my podcast to do well
of course we don't do anything
for it to be lost like no one does that
but what i do know
is that when i'm creating when i'm
producing when i'm writing
that's all i'm doing see the truth is
that only two percent
of the world's population can multitask
now the crazy thing is
those two percentages when people hear
that they think i'm in that oh i'm in
that two percent like everyone thinks
that they're in there
but most of us are 98 yeah and the truth
is there is no such thing as
multitasking what it is
is fast switching between two tasks so
the quality is just dropping because you
can actually
you cannot do two things at one time you
cannot no one genuinely can do two
things at one point i guess you could
maybe like
pat your head and do this the same yeah
you can't do something productive
at the same time right or creative and
so what i'm saying is that when you're
sitting here going this needs to be
number one you are reducing that things
ability to be number one
because it now doesn't have your full
focus right so so that's the difference
maker that you can want to be number one
there's nothing wrong with that
but you can't keep comparing what number
one is to someone else's goal too
because everyone's got a different
trajectory
like there are some people that are kind
of come in and do really well at one
thing and you're going to do really well
at another
and that's why competition has to first
be in your space
like don't compete in a space that's not
yours
right because now you're just trying to
be someone else again and you get
yourself
identity exactly exactly all of the
people that i know
who have become successful in any way
use a structured means to
organize their time they have lists of
things to do
like they have every day there's a list
of things to do that day
every week there's a list of things to
do that week every month
there's a list of things to do that
month you know at
every level of temporal resolution
there's a sequence of plans
and those plans are implemented on a
day-to-day basis
you you cannot be and
successful isn't the right way of
thinking about it because i'm not
thinking about you know
i'm not really thinking about rising up
the corporate ladder you know you know
what i mean
and that's sort of what success has come
to mean in our culture
that isn't what i mean you can't have a
life that
you're going to find acceptable without
that because you need the
vision and the plans to give you purpose
and direction that's where all your
positive emotion comes from all your
motivation
is laying out plans that are worth
attaining and then
observing yourself moving towards them
that's the source of most
positive meaning and then also without
that structure
you're so lost that you're going to be
anxious and overwhelmed it's really like
being in a foreign country
like isolated and alone with no map
i don't know where i am i don't know
what i'm doing
you know the rains are going to come the
storms are going to come and maybe it's
winter
and i don't know where i am or where i'm
going and the second thing i tell people
is
feeding your mind is great but you've
got to also strengthen your body and you
do that as an athlete naturally
i learned to do that because fear is
physical right you know you feel it and
if you go work out if you go lift if you
go run even if you're out of shape you
just go from an intense walk
that experience alone changes your life
every day in my life the first thing i
do before i do my priming
if i'm one of my homes i jump in some
hot water for fun and i jump in freezing
water and i have you know a river
you know and one of my homes in sun
valley and i've got cold plungers
everywhere so i go in 57 degree water
boom and what it does is like it's
teaching my brain
i do i tell my brain what to do and it
does it
it doesn't feel like it doesn't want to
do it and every cell in your body is
alive right
so it doesn't have to be like two hours
worth of something it could be something
to do for 30 seconds but it's training
your
body to be strong because a strong body
could strong mind and vice versa
if you want to learn three more amazing
habits the one percent used daily check
out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there other than the
five second rule
there is one habit that i have
adopted in the last three years that has
fundamentally changed me as a business
person